and a woman which doesn't mind and then
so China do you count like you know like
so if a man is
is gotten his his woman he's faithful
and all that so do you count the
occasional times when he kind of trips
and falls into the finals
well you know what it is
there was an episode I was like what did
you do triple fall in this because he's
like oh now he's like he's switching it
around he's like what if I man trips or
forces that occasional trip I'm falling
do you count that has been outside
that's not been outside oh so look I'm
gonna just put I'll be like this so like
40-year marriage he hooks up with a
couple you know a girl every couple of
years another one so at this point like
if your wife if you're telling your
wifey it's good so if telling your wife
he's gonna cause you to destroy your
relationship then you know what you're
doing in it I just think
friends do stuff loving their misses and
acting like they don't and then they do
something they get caught and they lose
their misses and it destroys a man's
life don't be one of those guys so yeah
so whatever you do prepared for in it
because
because
you might be in the comments crying
about oh my wife is taking half in it
you know what I mean so I just yeah you
need to know the type of relationship
you have because some women will allow
that one woman you do that once she's
taking everything so you have to know
the type of woman that you have is you
the type of woman that will forgive you
will forgive it's the type of woman
that's going to be like you know as long
as it wasn't the resources she's gonna
ask you so what did you do what have you
been buying this girl stuff what you
know like if you discovers that you know
you've been paying for a flat you bought
you've been dude like she might say okay
now I want to take take half but if she
just knows that it was one of those
things she'd be like you know I don't
want to split up the family the kids
don't have to know go buy me some maybe
you have to go and do some stuff to to
make up for it but I just think man them
whatever you do just just do it with
your chest honestly I don't I don't
understand like I don't understand it
how like guys will have the time and the
energy to like live two lives we're like
it's different if you've got two wives
and everyone knows everything like but
when you know when like guys literally
live like a whole life you know what I
mean like they'll have a whole family on
the side and it's just that level of
stress like you're not trying to
accomplish anything in your life like I
met um I met a guy that he told me he
was the youngest in his family
and
um he had four older siblings
and he said my older sibling is from a
different woman because his his um
father got the side chick pregnant and
the mom stayed with him and was
literally there when the side chick came
first Madness wait was this my was this
my boy
you don't know no no do you know why
because I literally know there's a same
story the same story no no but it's
literally I mean this was in the U.S no
this is the UK yeah yeah yeah
I I was like oh my God that like that is
another level
good woman when I say good woman I don't
mean like when people say oh he's a real
man for stepping up but I just mean some
women would love you so much that
they're gonna like you know what I mean
like I mean I think I could get over a
lot but oh my God that's like a kid that
would be that would be hard that would
be a kid you're breaking up your family
bro
ideally I like to think I wouldn't but I
think it would be really hard for me to
actually forgive a guy that he got
another girl pregnant it's just the
irresponsibility of it like if you're
gonna do it at least like don't get
another girl pregnant yeah yeah like any
of the drama I just yeah I think that
would really piss me off but I think I
think it's probably because
um if there's no kid involved you guys
can pattern it and kind of lie but once
as a kid
you gotta introduce the kid to like the
family
tell your sister is like I live a little
stressed man I can't even imagine like
how hot your head would be at that point
I
I mean that I think would be really hard
to forget would you accept if he's just
stepping up but not uh getting anyone
pregnant
do we have kids
um
no
oh no kids I mean were we are we married
no you're in a relationship oh um
that's an interesting question I I like
to say no but I think if I'm being truly
honest with myself for the right guy I
probably would and I let I like to think
I wouldn't oh how many times
oh how many times how many laugh lines
does he get
um
I think if it's like uh we're not even
married yet he's already doing it
um I think if it's like this is all okay
this is all like a prediction yeah and I
just know that like for the right guy
that I would put up with a lot and I
think most girls for the right guy would
put up with a lot I don't know how many
times does it disqualify him from being
the right guy if he's doing that to me
it would
um I like that in I the idea of it but I
just think I'm being real when I say
um I don't know the right guy could get
away with a lot what about they were all
hot chicks he was who are you quoting
with like you looked at them and you was
like yeah they were super hot
um
oh God I don't know this is all like a
prediction right like
um for a small part of you might respect
him more if they're like yeah I guess if
they were whales
which is usually the case to be fair
when guys step out it's usually for
girls yeah it's just like I've witnessed
other girls and it's like and they've
stayed for the right guy and I've stayed
before when someone like cheated and so
it's like how can I say I wouldn't if I
did and also I remember my mom said this
to me when I was younger I didn't
understand it um because one of my
sisters was was dating someone and she
was like oh mom was like I've got
someone from Africa for you and you
should try to hook her up I'm like Mom
she's got a man like what are you doing
she's like mom's like
um like so what that's just a boyfriend
what does it matter in it and I never
understood it about that time but you
know when they say it's not it's not
yours it's just your turn it's literally
that's all it is the only reason that
women have body counts is because
they've been with all these typical guys
that did not actually turn out to be
anything that was going to be anything
tangible so oh
if a girl says I've got a man and she
hasn't got a ring she's open game
everyone's open game you haven't like
and it's the truth for the matter you
might not like it yeah yeah sorry sorry
oh yeah but it's just that if you
haven't got a ring and you're not mad
you're single and that's how the
government looks at it and that's how
people look the only reason I won't
speak to you when you're outside is a
via ring on your finger I know some
people will but the one way to guarantee
that you will not get attention is when
a man looks and he sees a ring number
like she's taken apart from that
everyone's free game
I just think that like as women were
attracted to certain type of guys and
you know if a guy has all the like all
the things that you look for he might
cheat yeah so how can I how can I be
that mad if he cheats when it's like I
picked him but I think it takes quite a
secure woman to be able to actually
forgive it I I know it sounds
counterproductive but if you've got
secure in yourself and you can forgive
really easily I think you'll be able to
forgive it but I think if you're really
insecure it just ignites your
insecurities even more and then it falls
apart so it actually makes you more
secure for staying I think yeah well I
think the K I don't know if I could do
the kid I think that would be very cool
I don't know where the line is but I
think it's a child it's like it's like
for men like they're also a woman
cheated on me now she's out the door but
then I don't have kids the one when I
say she had kids it's one of those ones
then we then we say oh sorry then we say
um okay has was it is it public is it
embarrassment you start trying to damage
control because you're thinking right
what can I well how can I say face what
can we recover from here because we have
kids right but if you don't have kids
I'm gonna be outside but if we do have
kids I'll be real with you I'll be
thinking more about trying to trying to
but what can I do where at that point
you'd probably start stepping out though
it would be like yeah oh yeah
all right I'll forgive you like no one
knows I'll forgive you but like yeah I'm
not upset
we'll turn into whole swingers over here
we're dropping our keys in the bow
everything I have a different opinion on
when women cheat especially in the
marriage though yeah because I feel like
when a woman cheats in a marriage that
that is more than just emotions and I
feel like
there is that element of higher not
really understanding how dangerous a
man's life is in terms of the fact that
you're going to go and sleep with
another man when you have your whole
family with a different man that's like
that's like literally
starting like a war you know
but I think at least with me with women
I think you can actually prevent a woman
from cheating but I don't think he can
prevent a man from cheating please tell
me I think a man can be very happy and
satisfied and still step out but I think
with a woman the moment she feels some
neglect that's when her things are
heightened when she's not neglected
she's tends to be more loyal neglect
leads to I think when women cheats
because they think they can do better
but I think neglect determines whether
they think they can do better I think a
man that's not neglecting you you think
okay I'm upset but when he starts
neglecting you you think I can do better
I just I think you're either that guy to
hurry or not I think it also depends on
the type of girl in it like if she's got
her Tendencies and you marry her
like she might not even feel neglected
but she's just important maybe because I
the career I do I work with couples and
stuff a lot but I see men who are
millionaires and they're they're lives
are cheating with like a guy who's got a
bed set in like a Camden or something
that's too horny and no no because she
just needed to feel because he was Alpha
because she married the guy for the
resources and she wanted the sex when a
woman hasn't been given attention I'm
not saying it's a good thing but I do
think women are so attention driven that
when if you give her enough attention
she'll manage no no no no no because
what you're doing is you keep removing
it's like we have to give him an
accountability women married these guys
for resources yeah it was never the guy
which which set heart on fire but she
married for since remember I said she
married what makes sense right now the
problem with when you marry for what
makes sense and even when you're married
condition [ __ ] it doesn't matter if
it's 20 years at some point she can step
outside because she has it inside what
did she think she was marrying if he's
like like that that's the sorry I'm
sorry that just sounds so stupid to me
like from from her the girl who says
that because it's like my mom's married
to that guy my dad would go to India for
weeks at a time trying to get build
their company up but she knew he was a
workaholic you can't have like women
like we think we can have everything and
now you're gonna say oh I'm neglected
because my husband's going to work to
provide for my family so I'm gonna cheat
that's the most [ __ ] that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
and I don't want to think like my mom is
and I would never do this to a woman
like what what I've seen my parents
sacrifice for us for this first
generation is it's things that people
could never even do now because the
selfishness and you know I mean I watch
my parents live in two separate
countries still together but because of
that they gave their five children the
best opportunities to come into this
country as the first generation from
Cameroon right so it's like it's like
by what you say my dad fully neglected
my mom you know what the difference is
there though they had a joint Mission
yeah they're literally they're the
common goal and they were both working
towards certain in your example it's the
woman just marrying for resources that's
that's shallow but I would say that the
same thing like when a man has a woman
that's looking after their kids and
doing all of that being and then he
steps out because he just wants to have
sex isn't that just equally as [ __ ]
it's not the same thing I think the same
would be him funding another woman yes
that's that's more yeah yeah so wouldn't
that be the case if a woman is at like
how a man's providing for you and you're
just because you feel neglected and
you're cheating which I think is
ridiculous but it does happen
um wouldn't it be the same kind of
philosophy when a woman's looking after
your kids and being loyalty and cleaning
your house and cooking for you and
because she's not as sexy as she used to
be you're stepping out no do you know I
mean the same disrespect no I think the
equivalent is him spending money on
another girl
having a full side chick that he pays
her right I think that is take a dent in
your pocket though no even the fact that
if you're taking resources because at
that moment you know like
see at that moment you know it's more
than that like I never understand when
guys got girls and they step up but they
don't want to step out Pearl they
actually have like they start taking
girls on dates and stuff I'm like bro
what are you that's what I was saying
earlier like it's Madness
how do you have enough energy to be
dealing with that but the reason they do
this is because like their home lights
are [ __ ] boring and they grow in a
boring and women is looking after their
kids no but yeah but you're boring
they're going to meet a girl and she's
exciting right if he starts financially
funding her says you know I'm gonna pay
for you your studies yo he's cheating in
a different way how do I say it's not
about better it's just about different
yeah
there's nothing wrong you can't stop a
man because they just like varieties no
but if we look at if it works so if when
your wife cheats on you it's so much
deeper because in order for a woman to
do that she has to have some type of
emotion some women on demon time yeah
and we don't really talk about those
women because those are the women that
will just do whatever right but what
generally
to make your misses that loved you and
was only sleeping with you to go and
open her leg so next your missus is gone
she's not coming back your man's gonna
go do that he's gonna get post not
Clarity he's like oh my God I love my
girl let me go buy it to win yeah but I
can't equate it sexy in in infidelity
the same not to men not to men because
then what's gonna happen is but how
could you you had to have been turned on
by her to be no men were hole in the
wall and I'm not trying to make it
better I'm just trying to say I'm trying
to say he's different so if you judge
yourself by that you will never
understand why he can truly love you and
cheat yeah like you know what I mean do
you think there's certain cultures of
men that cheat more than others or do
you think it's all men I don't think
it's so this whole I I think that
certain types of men cheat more so like
if you're gonna date an NBA player or
um and like you know versus like the
computer nerd I feel like the commute
computer nerd is less likely to do it
they're pretty boiled down to options
though again
like the NBA player is going to have mad
options so it's a lot more difficult for
him not to cheat I don't know just like
you you get these guys that say I've
never cheated in my life I've never
stepped up
you actually can't even if you want to
you know even if you wanted you actually
can't go and draw another girl but like
for the guys that have girls throwing
themselves at him it's a lot more
difficult no you're right I think that
like like take Tiger Woods
and I used to I used to disagree with
this but then I was like you know what
if most guys had a Bus full of models
begging to sleep with them at the end of
the of a long hard day at work are they
gonna say no for 40 50 probably not it's
probably even a good man like one day
he's just gonna be like you know what
she's hot they're ready and her Tiger
Woods a situation as well like golf
golfers there traveling all around the
world
you know I mean
it's the fact that he was doing that and
he was still had a top game can you
imagine how the levels he was yeah he
was literally dealing with all these
women and he was just knock it in the
hole yeah this guy's a g we got Tiger
Woods man
maybe it motivated him he was like I
need to get more models but like yeah no
like yeah like no um [ __ ] so I actually
think when most when these men cheat you
know they don't cheat because they want
to cheat right I'm not taking the
responsibility away from them but men
are weak and women know how women are
some women can be so what's the word
unoffensive like they're so forward
didn't it and when you put a man that's
got these status got this Cloud got
these riches the types of women that go
up to him like you know men yeah like
you know and then some you know used to
always get caught like Ashley Cole and
John Terry you will see the woman that
would cheat with and you'll be like bruh
you just wouldn't understand it man
that's the worst day when you realize
you have to worry about ugly girls too
oh my God
ugly ugly fat girls that can cook you
need to worry about these women with
good attitudes oh hey these are the this
is the one that you slim women need to
worry about this is all you buy it's
hard as a woman because you can be
everything and you can still get rid
that's still an option like you you can
still cheat and that's not a problem so
that's why it's a bit harder in that
sense but I also think here it's the
west Western
like sit Pearl when did it become
cheating when did it change from like
polygamy to not like when did it because
what do you mean like
because I know it wasn't always like
this I knew like at different times
people used to get on like one man would
you know have a certain women some men
wouldn't get women and that's just how
it was well the divorce rate skyrocketed
with the development of birth control
um and that's like when the divorce rate
started to happen
and so the 60s yeah so we need to get
rid of birth control
well I mean they've been taking me
don't tempt me no but what I've
discovered about birth control is that
is like I didn't know it made girls mood
now it changes the type of guy you're
attracted to too so you're more
attracted like it your body is pregnant
so it tricks your butt like that's how
you don't get pregnant it tricks your
body into thinking you're pregnant so
what happens is like then when a girl's
pregnant she's looking for more of a
provider guy so she might pick a guy and
then get off of birth control and not
even be attracted to her husband I've
I've heard stuff like I've heard of that
yeah yeah it's black I just know like in
like with my girl and that yeah she said
like she don't she don't take those
stuff and then that was the first time I
probably you know like because all the
other women that I've dealt with have
dealt with birth control and they're
crazy so I think it um
and I think it makes sense because when
they say I don't want to take that
because I don't wanna and it could make
me not like you I heard that what do you
mean you could make me not like yeah you
might just turn around I don't like you
anymore yeah because it changes the type
of guy you pick and you're attractive I
thought she was Captain when she said no
that's true
that's true so I mean you could argue
that the divorce rate went up I saw a
theory about this the other day and I
thought it was interesting that maybe
the divorce rate went up because girls
are on birth control when they picked
their husbands and then after they got
the kids they weren't attracted to them
anymore
I don't know if that's true it's just a
theory I heard yeah I don't want to
remind them don't risk it don't start
gonna
imagine she just comes off at one that
realizes like I don't actually like
you're ugly
it's hard it's not it's a hard one don't
they because it's like it's like kids no
kids like it's difficult unless you want
to be just cheating with condoms the
whole time which is slowly
but you know you're supposed to do it I
saw um I posted it on put up that thing
when that girl was talking about oh yeah
um every guy I had sex with I had sex
with my period that's disgusting yeah
yeah she's like and I was like oh that's
a whole blood ritual there that's all
but you do realize that's what they used
to do in the olden days that's how they
guaranteed not you're not getting
pregnant in that don't have sex during
the period and when you wanted to get
pregnant is when you have sex I swear
you can still get pregnant
shoot up in the club of sort of heard as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tic Tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible